what is a line it is basically a thin
straight mark made by a pencil or a
marker and it extends indefinitely in
both directions but I can also draw a
line like this or like this it means
that we do not have a single way in
which a line can be drawn we just draw a
part of a line lines are generally named
with lowercase letters this can be
called line P or we can draw a line like
this and mark two points a and B this
will be called line a B line a B can
also be written as a B with a tiny line
drawn over a B so what is array array
starts at one point and goes on
indefinitely in one direction just like
four lines even rays can be drawn in
different ways what we draw is just a
part of array we can mark this point as
a and mark a point B somewhere on the
array we can call this R a a B or write
a B with a tiny ray over it this tells
us that the race starts at Point a and
goes indefinitely in one direction it's
a bit ironic er but the point at which
the rate begins is called the end point
of the Ray here a is the end point of
this ray which means it cannot be
written as ray ba or ba with a tiny ray
over it but line a B can also be written
as line B a we just need to be careful
when we are dealing with array now let's
get to the final concept in this video
look at what we have drawn here we can
see that it has two end points this is
called a line segment and it is a fixed
part of a line this is its specified
length and it does not extend
indefinitely in any direction if the end
points are a and B this can be called
line segment a B or it can also be
written as a B with a line segment over
it and yes we can also write this as B
a with a line segment over it a line
extends indefinitely in both directions
array starts at its end point and goes
indefinitely in one direction and a line
segment is a fixed part of a line